la chronique de l'environnement ce soir
au programme semaine du développement
durable et puis jardinage aussi malgré
la saison on va pouvoir s'y remettre
tout à fait donc nous recevons Johann
girbaau qui est chargé de mission
énergie climat à l'Agence Locale de
l'énergie et du climat de 50 ans en
iveline bonsoir et ensuite Amélie Aubert
chargée de communication à la Maison de
l'Environnement de manilé àau donc nous
allons commencer tout de suite avec le
jardinage puisque nous avons demandé aux
cantinois s'ils étaient adeptes de ce
loisir on regarde ouais ouais les jobs
d'été c'est intéressant ça permet bah
développer alors non je suis pas très
adepte au jardinage je laisse ça à mon
mari qui se régale et qui prend voilà
qui qui c'est sa passion à lui donc je
lui je lui laisse ah oui moi j'aime le
jardinage parce que c'est une détente et
en même temps un plaisir et un exercice
physique ouais je suis adepte au
jardinage bah c'est un passe temps c'est
sympa quand il fait beau
on profite du beau temps et ça permet de
sortir un peu de chez soi ah je jardine
oui je suis adepte du
jardinage parce qu'on voit ce qu'on fait
parce que c'est une détente parce que on
prend un bol d'air je suis un adepte oui
un adepte moyen et pourquoi bah parce
que parce que ça me
détend non parce que j'habite en
appartement et de ce fait bah je jardine
rarement quoi fait du jardinage oui
surtout dans la région c'est évident
parce que c'est une zone à faible
densité donc automatiquement il y a
toujours un petit morceau de
jardin alors la Maison de
l'environnement propose justement un
cycle de formation les plaisirs du
jardin Amélie Aubert pourquoi avoir
initié ces ces journées de de jardinage
parce que le jardinage est une pratique
maintenant très courante et de plus en
plus qui intéresse beaucoup de monde et
justement bah pas que ceux qui ont un
jardin mais aussi ceux qui vivent en
appartte qui ont un balcon voire même
pas de balcon on peut très bien faire
des semis chez soi et donc l'intérêt
pour le jardinage est grandissant donc
la maison deenvironnement a choisi
justement de développer ce thème donc
samedi nous avons rencontré Philippe
quin qui a animé donc grâce à
l'association villeeverte cette ce
premier cette première journée
pardon puisque le jardinage c'est quand
même le top 3 des loisirs préférés des
français c'était donc une demande de
votre public peut-être cette initiative
oui effectivement al entre autres mais
effectivement il y avait une attente
d'autant plus que la maison
d'environnement s'y prête très bien
puisqu'on a nous des parcelles de jardin
qui ont été justement réaménagé par
l'association villeeverte et pendant
qu'il la réaménageait normalement ça
devait être qu'un exemple on s'est dit
mais pourquoi pas faire une formation ou
en tout cas un atelier justement autour
de de ces cotagère on voit justement les
images de de cette première journée de
formation donc il y avait 17 personnes
présentes je crois avec des des conseils
très personnalisés on a vu que la
matinée avait plus par son aspect
justement très concret pour les les
personnes on a recueilli quelques
réactions on les écoute je suis un peu
novice euh donc c'était pour avoir des
petits conseils savoir les cultures les
graines les plants euh qu'est-ce qui est
le mieux
de pour pour mettre dans le dans dans le
jardin dans le potager ça m'a quand même
donné beaucoup d'idées sur la la
plantation des des la la façon de
planter la façon d'organiser jardin et
surtout de le de l'engressisser en fait
j'ai su comment amender mon terrain
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce que je devais
ajouter à la terre et quel type de de
d'organisme je devais ajouter
c'est-à-dire du Terrero du fumier un peu
de tourbe et limité en la terre de
brouillère donc la terre de forêt alors
on a vu que les participants étaient
très intéressés quand est-ce que la
prochaine journée de formation a lieu
alors la prochaine aura lieu le 20 avril
par contre nous sommes victimes de notre
succès puisquelle est déjà complète mais
nous allons en proposer une par mois
donc il en aur une également au mois de
mai euh donc ce sera le 25 mai avec à
chaque fois un thème parce qu'on essaie
de voilà de d'évoluer unématique donc là
ce sera plutôt les les techniques de
démultiplication au niveau des plans et
des semis pour préparer justement la
mise en plantation et enfin la prochaine
aura lieu le 22 juin là ce sera autour
des auxiliaires du jardin ces petites
insectes qui sont très utiles au
jardinier pour faire un un terreau très
nourricier très bien alors